hi Amy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
your question for Rachel and me hi thank
you for taking my call I am just
starting out I'm 26 and I'm a teacher
and I'm just starting out I have some
credit card debt and of course I have my
student loans that I'm paying and I'm
trying to pick out the fast way to
budget my money how much of each do you
have how much credit card debt not much
student loan debt student loan debt is
about $40,000 and my credit card debt is
about 3,000 good and what's your income
it's about 38,000 and you're single yes
okay Rachel yeah well any time you're
making an income of any amount Amy you
need to be budgeting so whether you have
debt or not a budget has to be a part of
your life and so I've learned this this
tool really does it gives me freedom
it's not constrictive for a long time I
always pictured a budget as like oh it
means I can't go shopping I can go on
vacation I can't do these things but now
you can do these things and be on a
budget you're just being intentional
with where your money's going and so
doing a written plan is going to be so
so key and so your your debt payments
will be in that at which you pay every
month on your debt plus everything else
so your rent or your mortgage your food
cell phone insurance anything you pay in
the month is going to go on this budget
so we teach the zero based budget so
that means your income of the next
coming month
minus your expenses needs equals zero so
every dollar you have coming in has a
name and your being intentional with
every single dollar and then you could
look at that budget say okay I want to
get rid of your this credit card debt
and so you can cut things in your budget
and actually put numbers to it and say
okay I can get out of debt next amount
of time and so we have a tool called
every dollar which is amazing it's an
app that I use so easy it's free so go
download that because that's really
going to help you start off if you've
never budgeted before like you or if
people out there have been budgeting
this is the best place to start it
really takes kind of a complicated
subjects and breaks it down into an easy
doable plan you can get every dollar as
an app on the App Store for your iPhone
it's free you can get or you can just
download and use it as an online
budgeting tool at
dollar calm either way sign up for it
use it on your desktop however you want
to use it whichever way you want to do
is completely free that way and it does
it when you write it down and you give
every dollar name it makes you feel like
you got a raise that's what you meant by
freedom well sure in your end control
because for so much you know so much of
time if you live without a budget you
just feel completely out of control you
have no clear your money's going and I
think that produces a lot of guilt shame
intimidation even start the budget so it
can't be an intimidating process to
begin but once you dig into it it's
amazing the freedom that comes with it
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here I hope
you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you